my guest tonight starred in the book of
mormon on broadway and the hbo series
girls now you can see him in the netflix
movies plural the boys in the band
and the prom please welcome the very
successful the very busy
andrew reynolds andrew how are you i'm
good i'm good thanks for having me
i like the game is that a game show wave
like like i'm in uh yeah like uh you
know hollywood squares
it's first wave uh thank you
uh so much you know it's so funny
because we've
spoken but this is like our first time
officially speaking
uh in the context of a talk show yes in
fact i
i'm fairly certain i have a photo with
you backstage
at the book of mormon yes um because my
co-star josh gad
always knew every celebrity that was
coming to the show
really very on top of it yeah and he
would tell us all like
guess who's here guess who's here and um
yeah and then you know sometimes
folks would make their way backstage
after the show which you did and you
were very
um you were very gracious about the show
and very kind
the show was obviously one of the
all-time uh funniest uh broadway
experiences
uh i've ever had uh just relentlessly
funny and
you guys were all so fantastic and i did
make my way backstage i actually
made my way if you remember on stage
several times during the show
um i like to make my
i like to make my presence known so so
i'm known for when i go to a show i'm
not happy just being spotted in the
crowd i like to make my way
up and do this in front of the crowd
during a scene and i apologize you would
have fit into that show
very easily i think you could have
definitely you could have been a
missionary
i yeah i very much have that uptight
missionary vibe and we've got the same
hair
that's right you know you know what are
you doing with your hair mine is
a combination of uh bathroom caulking
and helium what do you have in your hair
um
this is uh a little um like lift powder
and just uh
regret and mild depression
regret is so amazing people don't
understand what it can do for hair
volume
it gives it a real lift you know you
know so
it's funny that you say that that your
co-star and that josh gad
had sort of a radar for knowing who's in
the audience
i mean i'm just curious me aside
what were one of some of your more uh
celeb exciting celebrity
uh spottings while you were doing book
of mormon well i mean obviously
oprah was a big one that was a real big
one
um we all were very excited to to have
her there
um but the weirdest one for me was when
hillary clinton came with chelsea
clinton
and nana rodham um and that was very
we could see into the audience pretty
far so we saw them
sitting there and the fact that we were
that show was so
filthy in so many different ways that
like and i didn't have to do a lot of
that
but um the fact that we were singing
about like frogs and
clitorises in front of nana rodham just
didn't feel right
yeah i would think i don't know about i
usually i'm performing for an audience
that's come to see a tv show
and then occasionally there's been for
some reason
someone famous in the crowd and i
haven't
liked that i don't like that it gets i
get in my head
i think performing for a hillary clinton
or an
oprah um would be difficult like you'd
wanna you'd keep stopping and thinking
that's oprah and here i am i gotta stay
in character
do you know what i mean yeah i didn't
really have um
i'm not saying that i'm i'm not
professional
because i am professional but i would
look
directly into the audience sometimes and
be like
there they are there's the person um
because i would have a few moments that
i knew i could get away with it
but it was not like i remember when like
james franco was there and james franco
was sitting in the audience and i was
just staring at james franco
to to the degree in which he winked at
me
and then i winked back
i i was there the night james franco was
there and
i was staring at james franco
staring at you and then i winked at
james franco and he winked at me and
then at you
so it was like we all just passed it
around that seems right
i i'm sorry that's exactly what happened
it's okay um it's okay it was a long
time ago
okay so you have this moment which is
it's very much about what's happening in
the prom because it's that's all about
uh you know broadway and broadway uh
people in broadway musical theater and
dreams of being a big star
you land this role in book of mormon and
suddenly your life
changes but i'm curious i want to go
back before that
when you are in new york and you are
struggling
and basically that's the character
you're playing in the prom you're
playing a a struggling
uh performer who hasn't made it yet
um and is in his tending bar what kind
of jobs did you have
in in in new york before you made it
well
i was um uh i was always a good
interview
i always gave a really good in job
interview
so if people would think like oh he's
responsible he's from the midwest
like naturally and then i would work
i would work at places for like a day
and then get really tired of like the
idea of a day job
so like the worst one i mean by far
the worst one was i um worked at a gym
in brooklyn heights
and my job my shift was at 5am i had to
open the gym
and i um the night before
was out with people you know i was like
20 years old just like
knocking him back and when the time came
to open the gym i just decided not to
and so then i got a very panicked phone
call
around i don't know 5 45 which i ignored
because there were people like lined up
outside the gym because i had the keys
and i just didn't let them in and then
conan i thought maybe it would be a good
cover
to then call my boss and say i was like
i'm so sorry
i actually moved back to nebraska
um i don't live here anymore so that's
that's would be your excuse
as to why the reason i came here is i
moved back to nebraska
but i lived above the gym
i i actually my dorm was above the gym
so i lived in constant panic that i was
going to run in
to someone and i really did it very
dramatically like i was having some sort
of like
you know real crisis that i had to go
home
and and all the while i was just like
drunk at a gay piano bar
and um was not just didn't want to go
i just yeah so it's a problem because if
anyone sees you why aren't you in
nebraska and then you have to explain
that
you have a private jet that gets you
back and forth
even though you have no money i'm just
getting my stuff
uh i just needed to unpack or pack up my
things because i left in such a hurry
yeah i did that quite a bit i would um i
would leave jobs like that
because i think like at my core i knew
that i wanted to be an actor and i knew
i wanted to perform so like
the idea of a day job was like a real
hurdle for me and i know that's not
you know the case for most people um but
i had a real chip on my shoulder about
well i can't do this i was a host for
one night at a place called nacho mamas
by columbia university and i just i
like at a certain point people kept
coming in and i was like
i can't so i just went to the bathroom
for like an hour
um which is to be fair which to be fair
a lot of people do
at nacho mamas it's true it's very true
but i couldn't even handle it for one
night i was like there's too many people
i can't see people i'm in the weeds i'm
in the weeds
all right so fortunately for you things
worked out because i think if you had to
make it at a real job
i'm not saying what you do isn't a real
job but i'm including myself
i think you and i aren't cut out for the
for the legitimate world
no i no i have no marketable skills in
terms of
of helping people right or like doing a
service
like right yeah yeah i just don't yeah
no i
i've always thought that if i had been
born at any other time in history
i'd have been when people needed to know
how to build a stone wall
or um go plant crops they would have
just killed me immediately
because that would just be this random
wise ass that was consuming food
and saying stupid things in the corner
and they'd have just taken a stone and
killed me
it's true it's true i got a question for
you because i know
i know you're musically inclined yeah
kind of
you know you are you are have you have
you considered
doing like a musical on broadway when
broadway is
allowed to come back like is that
something that you would ever be you
know i had an uh the a part
that i've always been fascinated with so
much so that i wrote a simpsons episode
about it
years ago i was a music man and uh
susan strowman did a great revival of
the music man
i want to say about 15 20 years ago with
craig biarco who destroyed he was
absolutely pitch perfect and then he
left someone else came and then they
were looking for someone else
a third person uh to play the part of
the music man
and um susan strowman uh contacted me to
discuss it with me
and of course uh i found out that i i
couldn't do that in the late night show
at the same time so i was kind of
heartbroken
but well you know what you're in luck
because i think there is another revival
of the music man
is there okay yes hugh jackman is uh is
doing that
well yes now of course i i'm sorry but
i guess whose phone isn't going to ring
after this interview airs
my come on now come on people are going
to be like you could do it
well we got we locked in hugh jackman
did you see conan last night he was
talking to andrew reynolds yeah he said
jackman
get rid of him get that [ __ ] up our shoe
let's get o'brien
uh i gotta tell you that that monorail
episode of the simpsons is one of my
favorites oh thank you absolutely it was
my love letter to the broadway show i've
always wanted to be in so
someday in dinner theater and i'll make
you i'll make you be there
all right okay the prom i'm very excited
because
it uh didn't drop yet on uh netflix
but i was told that because you were
coming on the program i could get a
sneak peek at it
so i got a special code and uh watched
it last night and it's fantastic it's
beautifully done
all of you are of course uh terrific and
then i'm looking at it and i'm thinking
okay i'm talking to andrew reynolds
tomorrow and you have scenes a lot of
scenes with meryl streep
what's i mean how do you not step
outside your body
when you're performing with meryl streep
were you able to hold it together were
you a professional
no no no
definitely not professional no it didn't
take long i mean we had a really sort of
traditional
rehearsal process so we had about five
weeks in the studio where we all got
together and all learned all the
choreography and all that so that's a
very leveling
situation that everyone's coming in on
the same page we're all learning
together um so that felt really good but
then once we started
filming um yeah my wheels came off
pretty quick
and i was asking a lot of uh very direct
questions about
she devil and uh you know
death becomes her and i you would think
that you would probably ask about like
sophie's choice
um but i kept throwing her curveballs
right i would get in there with like
roseanne barr questions
yeah you figured everybody's asking her
about sophie's choice or kramer vs
screamer
i'm gonna get in there with she-devil
yep she-devil death becomes her like i
had a lot
a lot a lot of questions for her and i
will say she was
extremely patient and very um
very cool about nicole kidman also was
like very
understanding about me losing my mind
nicole actually
after like a you know a month of working
with her i was like
moulin rouge is one of my favorite
movies and i've seen it probably more
times than
any movie and which is odd because it's
very dark um
but i love it and it's comforting to me
that you know she dies of consumption i
don't know what that says about me
but um i just love that movie and
she was gracious enough to reenact her
death scene from that film
like while we were in between takes and
we were standing together like waiting
to go you know do this thing and
and she did it she did her full death i
hate to break it to you but she also
does it on cameo
for yeah and you know what it's pretty
cheap
it cost me eighty dollars and nicole
well that is
if nicole kidman was on cameo can you
imagine
i love the idea of huge stars on cameo
and they're in their bathroom with the
crappy
shower curtain behind them and they're
recreating you know de niro's doing
you talking to me you talking to me and
he's doing it and then you pay
110 yeah and you could get that scene
done for you and be like yeah happy
birthday mitch
and happy birthday mitch you looking at
me uh you know what i
i yes please well you're such a you're
such a
young man you've achieved so much and
you wrote your memoir and i thought like
wow you knocked the memoir off
early i'm saving that till i'm 92.
yours too much is not enough and it's
quite revealing
i mean i'm and your story is just
beginning you've got so much career
ahead of you i guess you'll be writing
another one
well i would i would love to i started
writing it
because you know when you're doing a
broadway show and you you get
sort of the the stage door kids that
come
to the you know to see you after the
show and
and they all a lot of them would ask me
for
like the shortcut basically like how did
you do and i could well there is no
shortcut and like
as much as i would like to say like i
plotted you know my role in the book of
mormon like that's just the
life of being an actor that like right
sometimes things hit sometimes things
don't and
um there were certainly a lot of things
that i thought would be a big deal and
that were not a big deal
and so um that's when i that's how i
started writing it was just like this is
what it's actually like to be
19 in new york city like you know
shuffling around
trying to get your career started um and
then
it sort of naturally turned into sort of
more personal stories about you know
like my dad dying
or about how i lost my virginity and all
that stuff and it's fine it's all
fine and good when you're writing it in
the privacy of your home
it's another thing when you know your
mother's going to read it and yeah
i'm talking about like regrettable blow
jobs like that's not
that's not great which which was almost
the title of the book i'm told
i it should have been if random house
had any
sense in their
[Laughter]
andrew reynolds is here with his memoir
regrettable [ __ ] andrew
[Laughter]
next up on fresh air
terry gross oh my word um
so i know that would be strange because
i'm thinking uh
if i were ever to write something my
biggest worry would be oh my god my
my family my my parents my brothers and
sisters are going to be
read about me losing my virginity during
obama's second inaugural and
uh i can't have that that's no
it's too revealing that's too revealing
it was late in life
um you know we have a we have a clip
here
uh from the prom and your character is
very funny
and i what i love is the the information
that's laid out that your character
uh is a struggling uh
a struggling actor broadway actor who
hasn't quite made it and so has to tend
barr
but um it's beautifully laid out that
you can't your character can't stop
talking about
his time at juilliard which does feel
like word would get around that's a type
that is definitely yeah no i i
dated a guy for many years who went to
juilliard and
they i'm not saying everyone
but i'm saying a lot of them like to
sneak that into conversation but the way
they do it
the way they do it is they say um their
group
number because it's not about the year
you graduated at julia right you say i
was in group
24 or i was in group which when that
when someone drops that into
conversation to be like well in group 13
i and you'd be like what is that and
they're like oh well at juilliard
i am perfect so that way
yes yes so i noticed that a lot i tried
to work that into the
film um but i think it was like a little
too
inside baseball to like have group
number
talk um but yeah that's a it's a real
thing it's like when people say like oh
i went to college in dc and you're like
just say georgetown like i get it
just say it then they say no i didn't go
to college in jordan
i literally i went to a technical school
at two-year technical school in dc
[ __ ] yeah it was the university of
phoenix but it was
in dc we have a clip here uh from
the prom and i believe this is where
you're working the bar
you haven't made it yet uh but you're
quite a chatty kathy
with these massive stars that is true
all right let's take a look who are you
trent oliver uh oh
we've done five shows together oh really
yeah oh my god
trent went to juilliard won't shut up
about it oh right
trend of course
why are you dressed like a waiter i'm in
between gigs at the moment
honestly dede i feel adrift as i did in
my days
before juilliard oh my god you see it my
passions are fueled by the power of lady
theater and how she can with the
gentle touch of her hand sculpt a human
soul
you know but we learned at julliard if i
could soliloquize
if you prick me do i not bleed
the prom uh is available on netflix
friday and it's terrific and also by the
way
uh boys in the band is available to
stream on netflix right now
and it is also extraordinary
you're you're just you're you're killing
it you're hitting it out of the park and
i'm very happy for you
thank you thank you very much that and i
i
i don't know that there's a connection
but i think
me coming to check out uh your
performance in book of mormon probably
made all the difference in your career
i think it did that's when uta called
was after you arrived
so um yeah because no one else was
paying attention to you or
the frankly the show
because you think franco said anything
about the show no he's too about franco
i called and i got the word out um
after it was already a huge hit did it
well thank you for that phone tree that
means a lot
by the way i will tell you that one of
the most controversial decisions my wife
ever made
was to take our two children
to see book of mormon and
at the time they were like 11
and 9. and i was like what the [ __ ]
she said it's such a it's good it's
really and i want it's fantastic
but there's vaginas and clitorises and
yeah well they've got to learn what a
[ __ ] is eventually so you know they
might as well
you know what i'm here to tell you you
don't need to know
i don't need to know
[Laughter]
you and me both andrew thank you very
much have a great day